the terrorists also targeted the seat of
american military power one of the
hijacked jetliners american airlines
flight 77 crashed into the pentagon
along with the 59 passengers and crew on
board
125 military and civilian personnel
inside were killed those victims will be
remembered at a ceremony at the pentagon
this morning cbs news national security
correspondent david martin is there
david good morning
good morning this will begin with the
reading of the names of those who
perished followed at 9 37 the incident
the plane hit the pentagon by a moment
of silence but i want to begin this
morning with the name of a survivor
retired army colonel marilyn wills
i was blown on the opposite side of the
room wheels was in a second floor
conference room directly in the plane's
path the loudest noise of an explosion
that i had ever heard the room
immediately got dark and smoke filled
the room
as i was crawling out the door someone
grabbed the back of my pants i said hold
on wherever i go you go don't let me go
i got you
her colleague was in dire straits she
said at one point she couldn't go any
further
because she had nylons on
and the nylons were sticking to her legs
they were melting on her legs
i totally get on my back i'll carry you
this is your escape room
this is my escape route from the era
this corridor has since been renovated
but this is what the pentagon looked
like after the plane struck you can't
see anything
it's dark
it's black it's full of smoke
this would be the windows she was trying
to get to that window but it was blast
resistant
when that window wouldn't break
i got mad at god you led me here
and now we're gonna die
because i came to a window that we can't
open
but god said not yet
not yet
and it opened
marilyn wills led five people including
lois stevens to safety through that
window
crawling through an inferno that left
offices looking like this she wanted to
go back and search for more but her
commanding officer ordered her out of
the building
after she climbed down marilyn willis
passed out and almost died on the way to
the hospital from all the smoke she had
inhaled she woke up three days
later to learn for the first time
that a plane had hit the pentagon
dana david thank you such a horrifying
day but those stories of courage
certainly also staying with us